Okay, Kobe.
You were an NBA star as a teenager.
What was it like having a giant paycheck at such a young age?
I don't get paid.
Okay.
Let's see.
Not yet.
It was awesome.
There's worse problems to have.
So yeah, it's pretty cool, yeah.
What was the first thing you bought?
Do you remember what you bought?
What was the first thing I bought?
I bought...
...nothing actually.
I put it in a bank and I saved it.
Hey, that's a good idea, right there.
That's good.
I think we all wanna know who's the next Kobe Bryant.
Let's see.
Well, Kawhi Leonard is amazing.
I actually love Kawhi.
I love James Harden.
I love Russell Westbrook.
But hopefully, they'll take the game above and beyond...
...anything that I have ever accomplished.